SUVs are still selling like hotcakes say
God wanted to profit from the hype
around off-road vehicles so even before
the Spanish company could launch its
first true SUV on to the market it
unveiled the Leon experience which has
the aura of an SUV on the basis of a
normal station wagon
yes yes car test of I know Dyson over
displays the cars big rear hatch it has
all-wheel drive so that even when fully
loaded and on slippery ground it still
reaches its destination with under ride
protection front and rear it has a real
outdoor feeling but do you need that
month of us off the experience also
comes in a gasoline and a diesel
front-wheel drive version the all-wheel
versions make sense if you regularly
drive off road or uh none paved roads if
you only drive in the city and on the
highway you probably don't need it we
tested a version with the all-wheel for
dr + 110 kilowatts of power
this version is manually shifted the DSG
gearbox comes only in the versions with
the most powerful engines Donald says
the st experience not only has lots of
trunk space the interior is roomy to the
standard sport seats provide good
lateral support and are comfortable even
on long trips his tip on options is to
get the + navigation system it has a
larger screen and connects easily with
your smartphone in the interior the
large round instruments are uncluttered
the design is sporting not stayed
interior characteristics specific to
this model include orange decorative
stitching on the steering wheel and the
experience logo the seat design is also
exclusive to the experience
the design of the experience is as
sporty as every other Leon the lower
part of the car with its unpainted
plastic parts makes a much more robust
impression than in cars with lacquered
bumpers
the sleek rear displays the experience
badge with its orange X the off-road
looked down below encourages a lacks
approach to washing after all a bit of
dirt and grit announce off-road
experience
I note says you don't always need an SUV
when there are station wagons with
all-wheel drive and an off-road look
that saves weight and makes the car more
agile the sea Utley on st experience is
sporty-er than a VW Golf all track and
cost much less than an audi a4 allroad
and if you want to save even more get a
leon st with all-wheel drive and do
without the off-road look if the styling
in the leon st is good enough for you
you can get all wheel drive and a 110
kilowatt diesel engine for 2,000 euros
less if you like in sporty-er you can
choose the FR version with the same
power but then there is little price
advantage over the experience
you